wisst ihr noch vor einem Jahr dachten
viele wir sehen die Sanktionen wirken
Russlands Wirtschaft wankt und heute ein
Jahr später ist die Politik ganz klein
laut die Russen trinken jetzt einfach
Ihre eigene cool Cola statt Coca-Cola
oder importieren Sie über Umwege und wir
wir zahlen mehr für Heizung Strom Essen
und so vieles mehr haben wir uns geirrt
wirken die Sanktionen gar nicht oder
zumindest zu wenig die Sanktionspolitik
wie wir sie aktuell sehen schadet der
eigenen Bevölkerung weitermachen auch
wenn das Mittel begrenzt funktioniert
wir müssen dazu stehen dass wir der
Ukraine nach allen Kräften die wir haben
auch helfen ich habe die Gründe für das
Scheitern und schaue ob sie diese
Sanktion trotzdem richtig sind
Sanktionspolitik ein inside politics
[Applaus]
mein Name ist Britta Buchholz zuständig
für Wirtschaft und Finanzen und deshalb
finde ich
Sanktionspolitik ein super spannendes
Thema ich garantiere euch nach diesem
Beitrag wisst ihr mehr als vorher zwei
Monate vor Kriegsbeginn also Ende 2021
Anfang 2022 da warnten ja viele vor
einem Krieg und die größte aller Drohung
war diese der Fimo sein wenn er in die
Ukraine einmarschiert werden die
Konsequenzen für seine Wirtschaft
verheerend sein
unsere Sanktionen können sehr hart sein
also es war die Drohung dann kam das
erste Sanktionspaket einen Tag vor dem
Krieg es folgten recht schnell zwei
weitere nur mal drei Beispiele
Sanktionen für 351 duma-mitglieder
teilausschuss aus dem Finanzsystem Swift
also das war ganz schlecht für russische
Banken und viele Oligarchen standen
plötzlich auf der Sanktionsliste die
ersten Bilder damals im März 2022 sein
so aus die Supermarktregale in Russland
lehrten sich allerdings auch wegen der
Hamsterkäufe viele Unternehmen verließen
das Land damals war der deutsche
Bundeskanzler für seine Art schon fast
euphorisch Russland die Börse ist
weitgehend geschlossen die Währung ist
abgestürzt es fehlen die Wiesen
ausländische Unternehmen verlassen zu
Hunderten das Land
doch das ist erst der Anfang so und
jetzt Wumm jetzt schauen wir auf 2023 12
Monate später nach zehn sanktionspaketen
in Russland sieht es so aus andere
Marken fühlen die Regale viel aus China
mcDonald's hat einen russischer Investor
übernommen es heißt nun lecker und die
Währung stabilisiert sich überraschend
der Rubel gegen kurz in den Keller und
nun ist er wieder fast auf
Vorkriegsniveau klar scheint Russlands
Wirtschaft ist erstaunlich stabil
erstaunlich oder warum funktionieren die
Sanktionen bisher nicht es gibt drei
wichtige Gründe speziell für Russland
und die schauen wir uns an
es haben zwar über 1000 Unternehmen
Russland verlassen aber viele machen
dennoch Geschäfte über
Tochterunternehmen oder indem sie noch
liefern schaut euch mal an was die Yale
University macht die listet Firmen auf
die trotz des Krieges weiter handelt
treiben sie nennen sie Liste der Schande
die ist beschämen entlang wir packen
euch den Link unten drunter
[Musik]
der zweite wichtige Grund der Import der
ist dem Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck nun aufgefallen es gibt deutliche
Umgehungen der Sanktionen und es gibt
auch deutlicher Umgebung aus Deutschland
heraus der Sanktionen ich will an dieser
Stelle einmal politisch sagen das ist
kein Kavaliersdelikt
sanktionsumgehung was bedeutet das also
das System ist denkbar einfach so
liefert die EU beispielsweise Handys
oder Kühlschränke zum Beispiel an
Armenien das Land verkauft diese dann an
Russland weiter Punkt einfach klingt
auch irgendwie vorhersehbar und ihr
fragt euch jetzt warum Kühlschränke ganz
einfach das Innenleben daraus lassen
sich Teile für militärische Geräte
nutzen viele sanktionierte Mikrochips
gelangen so ins Land allein das kleine
Land Armenien importierte 166 Prozent
mehr als im Jahr vor dem Krieg der
Verdacht über Umwege bekommt Putin
militärisch wichtige Güter das war ganz
spannend als ich für das Thema
recherchiert habe habe ich gesehen dass
der armenische Premierminister in der
Woche Scholz besucht hat beim Termin
kaum Journalisten das eigentlich nicht
so wirklich relevant erschienen aber
schaut mal wer erst im November den
armenischen Premierminister besucht hat
die Nähe von Putin und dem Arminia ist
also offensichtlich wen besucht Putin
denn überhaupt noch Scholz wollte ihm
jedenfalls klar machen dass handeln mit
sanktionierten Gütern kein
Kavaliersdelikt ist können wir sicher
sein dass nicht im ökonomischen Bereich
umso Sanktionen umgangen werden und das
ist natürlich etwas was wir als
Anforderung schon haben und wo wir auch
die Hoffnung haben dass das
beachtet wird was wir an Regeln haben
Problem ist es sind eben EU-Regeln da
wirkt das Hoffnung haben ja doch
ziemlich
hoffnungslos Marktwirtschaft lässt sich
eben schwer aushebeln ist ja auch nicht
nur Armenien Kasachstan China Türkei und
und und und wir haben ja bei Berlin
direkt über das Thema berichtet und da
gab es massenhaft Kommentare bei Twitter
und vor allen Dingen bei Youtube einer
davon den will ich mal exemplarisch für
viele andere vorlesen ist von Atze
Berlin der schreibt nämlich Sanktionen
wirken nicht abgesehen von der EU macht
kaum jemand mit andere große
Industriestaaten vor allem aber China
Indien Brasilien lassen sich tot und
profitieren von der Situation innerhalb
der EU führen die Maßnahmen zur
Wohlstandsverlust Armut und Freiheit
seht ihr das auch so oder muss man es
differenzierter sehen schreibt es gerne
in die Kommentare und nun komme ich zum
dritten Grund
Russland verkauft weiter zum Beispiel
Rohöl nach Indien nur günstiger als vor
dem Krieg Indien macht daraus diese den
eu-bürgertanken natürlich deutlich
teurer als vor dem Krieg Regeln dagegen
nun ja bei den Ölsanktionen wird man
nicht viel machen können man wird nie
verhindern können das Russland
bei über 200 Ländern in der Welt
irgendwelche Abnehmer findet bei Gase
ist vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger
weil man eben dort andere
Transportmöglichkeiten hat aber das ist
Öl irgendwo anders verkauft wird oder
die Kohle waren das verkauft wird lässt
sich praktisch nicht verhindern klar ist
die Einnahmen für Russland dürften
deutlich geringer sein als vor dem Krieg
Putins Kriegskasse Russland Öl und
gaseinnahmen brechen offenbar ein ihr
hört offenbar Problem bei all dem ist
dass man den russischen Angaben
überhaupt nicht trauen kann noch eine
Meldung es soll ein riesiges
Haushaltsloch da sein doch der IWF der
Internationale Währungsfonds ist ja
immer eine super Quelle wenn man
Wachstum von Ländern vergleichen will
der IWF hatte 2022 für Russland erst mit
einem Einbruch des Wachstums von 8 bis 9
Prozent gerechnet minus am Ende waren es
-2,1 erstaunlich und nun erwartet der
IWF für 2023 für die russische
Wirtschaft ein leichtes Wachstum 0,3
Prozent damit etwas besser als
Deutschland mit 0,1 Prozent für meine
Recherche habe ich den sanktionsexperten
der fu-interview Professor Lippmann und
er sagt die Wirtschaft sei schon extrem
angeschlagen nur dauert es bis wir es
sehen was wir sehen der Krieg läuft
weiter Putin scheint nicht getroffen
seine Wirtschaft funktioniert noch gut
genug um den Krieg zu finanzieren
erwartbar sagt Professor Lippmann wenn
das Ziel war den Krieg sehr schnell zu
stoppen innerhalb von Monaten wenn es
das Ziel war mittelfristig Wirkung auf
die russische Kriegsmaschine auszuüben
dann waren die Sanktionen vom Anfang an
einfach dazu nicht geeignet das kann man
mit Sanktionen nicht erreichen man kann
mit Sanktionen
wie gesagt langfristig technologischen
Potenzial Russland Schwächen dabei war
doch die große Hoffnung mittels der
Sanktion das Kriegsgeschehen zu
beeinflussen deshalb konnte ja überhaupt
mit ihnen gedroht werden ihr erinnert
euch ist das passiert bei einer
Pressekonferenz mit Harbeck hat eine
Journalistin eine sehr sehr wichtige
Frage gestellt doch einmal die Frage
inwieweit glauben sie dass durch diese
bessere Überprüfung der Sanktionen
Russland denn auch wirklich ja die Knie
gezwungen werden kann
so wird das ist und so schlimm ist ist
das auszusprechen ich glaube das
Russland nur auf dem Schlachtfeld in die
Knie gezwungen werden kann wenn die
Sanktionen aber nicht helfen den Krieg
zu beeinflussen was bringen sie dann
denn eins ist klar die Deutschen sind
massiv betroffen von den hohen
Energiepreisen die BASF zum Beispiel
streicht 2000 Stellen auch viele in
Deutschland und das weil die
Chemiebranche bei solch hohen Preisen in
Deutschland schwerlich produzieren kann
manche fragen sich leidet Deutschland
gar mehr als Russland erinnert euch der
IWF prognostiziert Russland für dieses
Jahr sogar ein leicht ganz leicht
höheres Wachstum als für Deutschland was
folgt daraus ich fand es ja spannend
dass die Opposition zu fragen und die
die ist uneins die CDU steht ja fest an
der Seite der Ampel in dieser Frage wir
müssen ihnen ganz einfach auch zu
unseren Werten stehen zu unseren Zusagen
stehen wir müssen dazu stehen dass der
der Ukraine nach allen Kräften die wir
haben auch helfen
der Bundessprecher der AFD die waren ja
immer gegen Sanktionen und als ich ihnen
Interview ist klar dass es wie ein
ballfostor er hat schon immer gesagt
sanktionen müssen weg und jetzt fühlt er
sich bestätigt die Sanktionspolitik wie
wir sie aktuell sehen schadet der
eigenen Bevölkerung mehr als der
russischen wir Schaden unserer
Wirtschaft wir schauen unseren
Unternehmen und die Bevölkerung in
Deutschland leidet weil sie hohe
Energiekosten zahlen muss aber dass die
deutsche Wirtschaft getroffen wird das
war ja allen klar manche sehen in
Sanktionen mehr eine Symbolwirkung klar
zu machen von euch nehme ich kein Geld
mehr mit dir mache ich keine Geschäfte
wäre es wirklich vorstellbar dass die EU
gerade weiter mit Putin Geschäfte macht
schwierig dennoch ist das ja ein Dilemma
dass die deutsche die europäische
Wirtschaft so stark getroffen ist es ist
ein Dilemma und es ist ein Dilemma dass
man immer hat wenn man Sanktionen
anwendet Sanktionen können überhaupt
wirksam sein nur wenn es intensiver
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen gibt das heißt
aber auch in dem Augenblick in dem der
sanktions Paket beschlossen wird leiden
darunter auch eigene Unternehmen und das
ist genau das schwierige weil man sich
dafür entscheidet Sanktionen zu
verwenden muss man ganz genau überlegen
was man damit erreichen kann mit welchen
Kosten es verbunden ist und welche
Gruppen davon betroffen werden also
pauschale schnelle Entscheidungen sind
da leider schlecht beraten wir können
nun auch nicht sagen die Politik war
völlig überrascht wenn wir Christian
Lindner vom März 2022 hören also vor
einem Jahr der wirkt ja prophetisch wir
treffen Russlands Banken wir treffen
Russlands Oligarchen wir treffen
Russlands Wirtschaft die Emotionen die
wir beschlossen haben
diese Sanktionen sind auf Dauer angelegt
wir brauchen einen langen Atem wir haben
diesen langen Atem oder man kann sagen
in seinem Ministerium war allen klar was
Sanktionen erreichen können oder was
eben nicht dennoch hadern viele mit dem
Instrument Sanktion wirken sie oder
wirken sie eben nicht mein Fazit wäre
kurzfristig weniger als erwartet mehr
ein Signal von überraschend
geschlossener Gegenwehr Russland muss
seine Gas und rohölkunden woanders
suchen langfristig könnten die Sanktion
natürlich schon wirken ein britischer
Historiker drückte das neulich so aus
das riesige Land werde geopolitisch kaum
noch mehr sein als die Tankstelle Chinas
was meint ihr hat die Politik die
Wirkung der Sanktionen überschätzt was
ein großes Missverständnis dass sie den
Krieg beeinflussen könnten ich freue
mich auf eure Kommentare und auf das
nächste inside politics